hello and welcome to the first and
probably last ever 2021 kicks draft this
is a historic day where the most
influential groups from all over the
world will select the footwear that will
represent them until the end of time and
without further ado we go now to our
sneaker commissioner who will announce
the first pick by none other than the
new yorkers
with the first pick
in the 2021 kickstart
the new yorkers select
timberlands
jamel i've seen that coming a mile away
for more on this peek let's go live to
the big apples
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations to new york and tim's or
butters or some call them that's a
perfect fit you know jamil they say the
leather on the top of the timberland
boot is for that harsh new york winter
oh wait i'm getting a message it seems
that the tick tockers now have the
number two pick they were supposed to
have the number 10 pick but they stole
that because
that's what they do
uh let's throw it to the commissioner
with the second pick
tick tocker is select
white and black
nike blazer
[Applause]
[Music]
well they do seem happy yeah that's
until the phone turns off then the life
is full of darkness got that right rob
[Laughter]
with the third pick
dad's select
monarchs
i wasn't sure about this one i heard
flip flops specifically in the winter
were high on their list the only problem
with that is flip flops aren't going to
hide kevin's bunions too well
come on guys what the [ __ ]
well this first round is really shaping
up to be a good one what other surprises
can we expect well white girls are up
next and i'm not even gonna predict what
they'll do you can say that again
brother
don't say that again i won't
now before we go to our fourth pick
white girls let's talk to our kicks
draft analyst john king from cnn
john thanks rob and jamel well folks as
you can see it is turning out to be an
incredible night some pretty spicy picks
coming up nurses may trade to swipe
crocs from the bad bunny fan club new
england frat boys well they're being new
england frat boys hoping their new
balance 550s remain an option one thing
we're told to watch out for oregon's
chill dude selection source on the
ground says it is possible they may
forego their beaverton allegiance
altogether consider waving their pick
entirely to remain barefoot in public
we'll bring in that video as soon as we
get it as pix come in and as grails
leave the board i'm going to be here
tapping around the map
hopeful optimism you might say just like
i'm refreshing my sneakers out thank you
so much for breaking that down for us
john well it's about that time to see
what white girl at number four have
decided
with the fourth pick
white girls select
fila disruptors
[Applause]
[Music]
for more on white girl's pink let's go
to our white girl correspondent and
white girl megan
clearly a lot of excitement here at
white girl headquarters now there were
rumors you all were gonna take dirty air
force ones walk me through the
decision-making process to take the feel
of disruptor instead
well pretty much we just wanted to be
taller
and uh there's like a tenant platform on
this so it ended up being like a
no-brainer plus ariana grande loves
these shoes
she's like our god
amazing insights from now what's your
name denise
can we take a selfie absolutely
[Applause]
back to you
send that to me denise uh me too dm's
open let's go to commercial break but
stay tuned we've got more of the 2021
kickstart coming right up
bro i'm gonna tell you like this if dc
doesn't drive phones
i might kill somebody you like gordon
hayward take new balances from us how to
[ __ ] gordon hayward could have picked a
whole pig to himself